MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
all for coming, especially
for making the trek
all the way down here.
Dr. Phelps won the
Nobel Prize for what
he calls the unified
field theory of economics.
Actually, he didn't
call it that.
No, you did.
But today, he's going to talk
about capitalism and what
makes a capitalist economy
different from either
a socialist or a
corporatist economy.
I had a speaker a
couple years ago,
Luigi Zingales from
Chicago, who is
kind of a soul
brother of Dr. Phelps.
If any of you came
to that, you'll
recognize the themes here that
neither the right nor the left
would be totally happy
with what Dr. Phelps has
to say-- the left for
reasons he'll tell you about,
and the right because they tend
to favor big business rather
than-- or rather, I would say
that being pro-business is not
the same as being pro-market.
So without further ado, please
welcome Dr. Edmund Phelps.
[APPLAUSE]
EDMUND PHELPS: Thank
you, Bob, very much.
It's a real pleasure
to be here at Google.
This is my first time here.
And I'm very pleased
to talk about
my book, "Mass Flourishing."
The book is about
the modern economies
that arose in a few nations
in the 19th century-- Britain
and America, around 1820,
later Germany and France,
economies that remained
well functioning
until the middle of
the 20th century.
They were the
marvel of the world.
The wonder was not so much
the high wages and wealth.
There was rampant prosperity,
material and non-material.
Mark Twain spoke of, quote,
"the drive and push and rush
and struggle of the raging,
tearing, booming 19th century."
One kind of prosperity
was classical.
Modern economies
were achieving growth
of economic knowledge, thus
growth of productivity.
Hence wage rates and
working conditions
were improving
throughout the economy.
A worker could just
ride the rising tide.
And modern economies and
non-modern economies,
through trade and
technological transfers,
could tap into that
kind of prosperity
in order to catch up.
Another kind of prosperity was
modern and of key importance.
There were gains
in one's earning
power from one's new insights
and skills, and gains in one's
satisfaction from new
experiences in one's work.
These gains, material
and non-material,
are rewards of
initiating and creating.
They represent succeeding, or
to use the term I will use,
prospering.
Non-modern nations could not tap
into that kind of prospering.
Never before had prospering
been within reach
of large and increasing numbers.
Before the first
modern economies,
around 1820, economic
knowledge, thus productivity,
was virtually stagnant,
even in economies
that were the jewels of
mercantile capitalism,
such as Spain and Holland.
The concept of job
satisfaction was unknown.
For me, the lone shepherd, bored
by the routine and isolated
from his fellows,
symbolizes that system.
The new mass prospering was
brought by mass innovating,
though the historians spoke
only of resources, efficiencies,
and increasing returns to scale.
In the stream of new
products and methods,
some found adoption by
consumers or producers,
changing the complexion
of the economy.
In Britain and America,
especially, there
was a welter of innovations,
large and small, not
just headline innovations.
In an 1858 lecture,
Abraham Lincoln
said of America that
there was a perfect rage
for the new, a rage that was
rife among makers of products
as well as users of products.
Where did ideas for
innovation come from?
The German historical school
and the young Austrian Joseph
Schumpeter believed that
innovations originated
from a succession of discoveries
by scientists and navigators,
who were generally
exogenous to the economy,
and the commercial applications
of these discoveries
by entrepreneurs.
But the modern economies possess
their own economic dynamism--
the desire, the capacity,
and the scope to innovate.
This led to an outpouring of
imagining, tinkering, testing,
and trying out.
These economies were capable of
indigenous innovation, not just
the exogenous innovation of
the mercantile capitalism.
The system of dynamism was
more effective the more open
it was to contributors
down to the grassroots.
And the modern economies were
rather open to the grassroots.
Human resources of
initiative and imagination
were devoted to innovating,
not just producing and trading.
Dynamism ran high to the
middle of the 20th century.
No wonder there was
mass prosperity.
No economy before had
drawn on the imagination
of such a wide range
of the nation's minds.
This dynamism required
entrepreneurs and financiers,
of course, just as the
sporadic innovations
of the mercantile period did.
Their judgment and
expertise was needed.
Yet dynamism further required
innovators, innovators
with the insight,
imaginativeness,
and vision to dream
up new products that
might pan out and win adoption.
Yet the idea that business
activity in a free market
can always be depended
upon to possess
the dynamism for indigenous
innovation is a mistake.
The right stuff is required.
Innovators often have to
buck conventional thinking
and to break away from the
traditional ties to families
and friends.
Also, innovating requires a
social and political climate
that is receptive
to innovations,
despite the disruptions
that they're apt to cause.
Was the modern
economy desirable?
Modern economies
yielded a sustained rise
of material benefits, including
rising productivity and wages,
decreasing disease,
poverty, and pauperism,
and increasing inclusion.
In the worst factories, workers
at least had escaped the farm.
The more radical impact of the
new economies was non-material.
They changed the very
nature of life and work
where they took root.
There were experiential rewards
from working on new problems,
gathering insights, imagining
and creating novel things,
testing them in the
workplace, and trying them out
in the marketplace.
And there were
existential rewards
of self-discovery
and personal growth
from journeying
into the unknown.
The adventurous and
exploratory spirit
of the modern
economic life emerging
in the 19th-century
cities was reflected also
in the arts of the period.
Of course, this
transformation depended
on the development
of institutions
that enabled dynamism, including
various legal rights, laws
governing corporations,
and financial institutions.
The real crux, though, and
one not given enough weight
until now, is the rise of
modern values, the spread
of modern attitudes,
precepts, and beliefs.
These modern values
could be grouped roughly
under the headings
of individualism--
thinking for oneself,
working for oneself,
willingness to break
away from one's group,
break away from convention.
Vitalism-- relishing challenges,
overcoming obstacles,
satisfying curiosity, competing,
taking initiative, acting
on the world.
And self-expression-- imagining
and creating, demonstrating
an insight by testing it,
voyaging into the unknown in
hopes of making a mark.
A basic thesis of the book
is that the slow accretion
of these modern values finally
achieved the critical mass
necessary to whet the desire
in individuals to innovate,
to spur capabilities required
to innovate and boost
the willingness in society to
give wide scope for innovation.
The book documents
the modern values,
from the onset of
the modern era,
in Jacques Barzun's terminology,
to its winding down,
roughly from 1490 to 1940.
Individualism began
with the humanism
of the late
Renaissance, vitalism
with the quests
of the Baroque era
and the curiosity of
the Enlightenment,
and self-expression with
the Romantic period.
This cultural heritage
belonged to the world,
certainly to all of
the Western nations.
But it is implicit in the book
that some of these nations
did not fully assimilate
it into their life,
into the values
that they act on.
Ultimately, some
severe reactions
to the modern economies set in.
The fluctuations and
disparities in outcomes,
and even in prospects,
typical of modern economies
and the endemic unemployment
led to socialist opposition.
Some nations moved part of the
way to a socialist economy,
seeing more planning
and more state ownership
as a step towards
stability, equality,
and greater employment.
Generally speaking,
the socialists
spoke of greater development of
people's capacities to produce,
but showed no
consideration or awareness
of the deeper goals
of individuals,
the non-material
rewards deriving
from a life of self-expression,
such as exploration
and creativity.
The socialists neglected, then,
to provide for innovation.
The rudderlessness and
the social upheaval
wrought by the
modern economies led,
in the interwar years,
the 1920s and 1930s,
to a corporatist reaction,
a reaction invoking
some traditional values
found in the Middle Ages
and even in as long as
mercantile capitalism.
The corporatist critique in
Italy, Germany, and France
drew upon a set of
traditional values,
seen there in the
left hand column.
The corporatists
hated new enterprises
invading towns and
hated new money
upsetting traditional
ways, wealth, and status.
So they hated the lack
of society's control
over the economy.
The essence of their
thought was a revolt
against individualism
and self-expression.
For them, what mattered
was the good of the nation,
not the individual.
And the government got to decide
what is good for the nation.
The classic corporatist
economies of that time,
of interwar years,
retained private ownership
but left little
control to the owners.
They replaced competition
and the market
with a tripartite system of
business confederations, labor
unions-- both with little
power-- and the state.
Corporatist institutions
and policies
aimed at social
protection and solidarity.
These economies were
conspicuous for their patronage
and lobbying, not to mention
cronyism and nepotism.
Mussolini, a
leading corporatist,
promised higher productivity
through innovation,
but without arranging
much for innovation.
Corporatists and
socialists have continued
to claim, right up
to the present day,
that their systems boost
economic performance
on their measures.
But data from the
1980s and 1990s
do not support those claims.
In brief, the more
socialist economies
did not excel at employment, and
the more corporatist economies
did not excel at growth.
Those economies have
proved so woefully lacking
in innovation, indigenous
or even exogenous,
that they have been unable
to realize their own goals.
The book tests its thesis
that highly prospering nations
require high dynamism,
and for that, they
have to be high
in modern values.
To simplify the
investigation, the book
tests whether to be
highly prospering,
nations have to be
high in modern values.
That is done by using the
prevalence of several attitudes
reported in household surveys--
a preference for jobs that
are interesting, that involve
initiative, that offer
change, that present challenges,
such as competition--
to represent the prevalence
of modern values,
and using the prevalence
of job satisfaction
in a nation as a measure of
the prevalence of prospering
in that nation.
Among 18 countries
in the OECD, the six
where job satisfaction
was widespread
were all above average
in modern values.
The more prevalent
modern values are,
the more prevalent
job satisfaction is.
And by the way, if that
feels like it's not
quite the question that
should have been answered,
the same is true for
life satisfaction.
Also, the countries
where traditional values
are more prevalent tend
to report very low job
satisfaction.
Now let's return to
the book's narrative.
In the post-war years,
Germany and France
resumed rapid growth, and
Italy found new growth,
but it was mostly through
technological transfers.
There was mounting evidence
of lessened dynamism
in those countries.
In Britain and
Germany, later France,
the loss of
indigenous innovation
appears to have
been considerable,
though concealed by
continuing technology
transfers from America, as
long as the supply lasted--
and it seems to have lasted
until the late 1990s.
In America, the growth
rate of productivity,
after subtracting the part
attributable to growth
of capital per worker,
fell in the early 1970s
to about one half of what it had
been consistently in the period
1922 to 1972, and it remained
there ever since at about half
of its former self,
with the exception
of the years of the internet
build-out, 1996 to 2004, when
there was a brief respite.
What has happened
is that innovation
has narrowed, I
believe, diminishing
in most established
industries in particular,
and of course rising in some
other industries, generally
new industries.
Predictably, the declines
of innovation in these four
countries were followed
by a major ballooning
of unemployment in
each one of them,
which is further evidence
that something went wrong.
What are the root causes?
The book lays much of
these declines of dynamism
to a rise of traditional
and anti-modern
or anti-business values
in post-war times
compared to prewar times, when
dynamism was still strong.
I will focus on cultural
shifts in America,
leaving Europe to one side.
There has been a spread of the
much-discussed money culture
in America.
Hence fewer people
prefer years of austerity
trying to innovate with a
doubtful pecuniary payoff, only
the non-material
reward, to working
in jobs that pay really well.
In many people, the
desire to make money
has grown into greed.
A survey of financial people
found that about half of them
would engage in inside
trading if there
was no risk of being caught.
This widespread
desperation for money
must lead to a lot
of self-dealing
by managers and others in large
firms, mutual funds, and banks,
pathologies that
must divert managers
from innovation
to short-termism.
In America, at least, there
is a much-commented rise
of an adolescent culture
that's low on concentration
and self-discipline.
Relatedly, there has been
a striking devaluation
of achievement.
Witness the denigration
of creative figures.
There was just
another one last week.
Tighter traditional values
tie many a young person
to their families, circle
of friends, or community.
Few people are telling
the youth these days,
"Go West, young man, go West."
A new culture of entitlement
brings pressure on companies
to allow employees to meet
family needs by working
at home, which is
bad for innovation.
A key precept of
the new corporatism,
the right to social
protection from the market,
has led to pervasive patronage
from politicians and campaign
contributions from
corporations and labor unions.
When established
corporations are protected
through special
interest legislation,
such as evergreening
of old patents,
these corporations become
less interested in innovation
then in rent-seeking.
And after they've
got their carve-outs
and their special
interest tax deductions,
outsiders with potentially
innovative ideas
are less able to enter.
So they cannot innovate, while
the insiders, now protected,
can drop whatever defensive
innovation they were going
to do.
They don't need to innovate.
So it's a double whammy.
The nexus between
private and public
in education, medical
care, and pharmaceuticals
is especially harmful-- is
especially impeding innovation
there.
Another precept of
the new corporatism,
that the state is needed
to set important directions
for the economy, leads to elites
in government playing a larger
role in the nation's
attempts at innovating,
and ordinary people doing
grassroots innovation
to a smaller role.
And it is the ordinary people
doing grassroots innovation
who, being up close to the
problems and the opportunities,
have an advantage at innovating.
Yet another-- that's it.
I'll make a cut here.
Thus, America has
strayed pretty far
from the pioneer spirit captured
by Willa Cather and the movie
"Shane," and the new
values have choked off
much of the modern
economies' dynamism,
not just caused a loss
of efficiency, which
was the focus of
books by Mancur Olson
and, before him,
Jean-Baptiste Say.
Modern values, if
they are predominant,
spark the engine of
human imagination
that drives the
innovation that is
central to the modern economy.
In contrast, some traditional
or anti-modern values directly
inhibit people from making
attempts to innovate.
And these values,
if they prevail
over modern values, foster
corporatist policies that
impede or even block innovation,
if there are any attempts.
What sort of an economy
ought we to aim for now?
What is the good and the just?
Some serious people
have suggested
we say goodbye to growth.
Now my book agrees
that it is especially
the non-material rewards that
were the great gift to nations
with modern economies.
But now, prominent
economists and commentators
are proposing to say goodbye
to dynamism and prospering.
They are advocating a focus
on the quality of life,
amenities like sports stadiums,
comforts like clean streets,
and security.
A well known report
from the OECD
views wealth and leisure
as the highest goods.
My book argues that an
economy, to be a good economy,
must be structured
to offer participants
prospects of the good life.
It would be an injustice to
deprive people of prospects
of the good life, prospects
for the good life.
Further, the book
sees the good life
as the conception
developed across centuries
in the modern era by a
succession of philosophers
and humanists, a
life of exploration,
creativity, and discovery.
This modern conception
of the good life
derives from Pico
della Mirandola,
at the end of the 1400s, Martin
Luther, Montaigne, Cervantes,
Shakespeare, Hume, Hegel,
Kierkegaard, Nietzsche, William
James, and Henri Bergson.
Philosophers use the
word "flourishing"
to characterize
this sort of life.
It's apparent, I think,
that the prospering
I was describing before, that
came to the modern economies,
is a splendid example of the
philosophers' flourishing.
Moreover, ordinary people
have no other source
of flourishing but
the business economy.
Where else are they going
to find the opportunities?
So the modern economies
were unique and necessary
for the provision
of the good life
to large numbers
of participants,
all the way to the grassroots.
Now I've just talked about the
good life and the good economy.
An economy both
good and just must
be geared to offer
those with the poorest
prospects of the good life
the best prospects possible.
Further, if some
people are not oriented
toward the conception
of the good life,
this modern conception,
a just society
will allow them to operate
their own parallel economies.
All this breaks with
accepted thought.
Both the left and the
right and the corporatists
overlook the world of
creation, with its imagining
and venturing and the resulting
personal growth, in favor
of materialist criteria,
such as leisure and wealth.
But the sort of quality life
that they appear to envision
is no substitute
for the good life.
The good life is a wild
ride through an economy
with an open future,
an economy offering
unimagined rewards, a life
of Kierkegaardian mystery,
Nietzschean challenge,
and Bergsonian becoming.
This is what we
must hope to regain.
To conclude, I would just make
one comment about strategy.
I would say that it will
be necessary to broaden
to the whole economy the
grassroots innovation that
found its footing, especially
in California, in garages,
in the music business,
and in the film
industry and a few
sparkling companies.
The nation must aim for
this more participatory kind
of economy, for a
grassroots revolution.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So Silicon
Valley is often
felt as a pocket of
innovation, which it is.
But in, let's say, 1999,
there was a huge number
of copycat companies
trying to just sort of get
big, fat [INAUDIBLE].
How do you distinguish
between and encourage
the real innovation versus
just sort of pure exploitation?
EDMUND PHELPS: Well, that's why
we have wizened old financiers
with green eyeshades
and tons of experience,
who use their intuition
about what might fly and what
probably won't.
And we like to leave them in
charge of the nation's purse.
They will finance what seems
good to them and say no to what
doesn't.
Of course, there's
often or sometimes
a diversity of opinion.
By the way, Schumpeter
thought that the financiers
were omniscient.
They had some sort of
mystical knowledge of-- I
don't think that.
But this is simply-- the fact
that nobody has foreknowledge
of what's going
to work and what's
not going to work
is part of the game.
You might say the
downside of the game,
that there are an awful lot
of people who try and fail.
But I don't see any
alternative to that.
AUDIENCE: I was always amazed
at people like Henry Ford.
How was he able to expand
so quickly, so fast
in the US and worldwide?
There was no internet,
no fax machines.
He was putting up
factories, which
were a lot of capital investment
and a lot of know-how,
how to build a large factory,
something they'd never done,
so a lot of unknown that we deal
with today, a lot of unknown.
And what can we learn-- how
was he able to move so fast?
[INAUDIBLE].
EDMUND PHELPS: I do discuss
Henry Ford for a paragraph
or so, which doesn't make
me a profound Ford scholar.
But I think what
distinguished Ford
was, as some have said
before, principally
a remarkable vision.
And he used to insist that he
didn't know a damn thing more
about building a car
than anybody else,
and he just, in every case,
used state of the art methods
to assemble his car.
So it wasn't in the car.
It was in his vision of
what the demand for the car
would be if the
price were right.
And the price could be right
if the demand was big enough.
And so it's something like that.
I don't know about where
he got his capital.
Probably he started with
a relatively small amount
of capital but quickly
expanded once he
got the confidence
of financial people.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Of all the companies
in the world right now,
which one do you think
is the most modern
and has the most dynamism?
EDMUND PHELPS: Thanks
for the question, Bob.
It gives me a chance
to talk about China.
It's a very curious
thing, but I got
invited to be dean of the
New Huadu Business School
in the early months of 2010.
I had hardly set foot
in the business school,
let alone been a dean.
But by this time, I was
interested in innovation,
so I saw it as an opportunity.
So I started to go to China
regularly for about two weeks
at a time, about
four times a year.
And at first, I
thought, ah, China.
It's all about
technological transfers,
principally from
the United States.
There surely is no
indigenous innovation here.
And then some of my colleagues
among the professors
reinforced this
prejudice by saying,
yes, here in China, people
are afraid to stand out
from the group.
They're conformists, they're
timid, et cetera, et cetera.
So I thought, well, that's that.
But then my handlers
started to push me out
into visits to
factories after a while,
and I began to see with
my own eyes that, my gosh,
these people, maybe
they're not innovating
the socks off of the
world, but they certainly
are thinking about
innovation, and they
are very sophisticated.
And it must be only
a matter of time
before some of the ideas they
have work and then make people
sit up and take notice.
There was a zipper
factory that, to this day,
impressed me enormously with
its creativity and its spirit.
They knew everybody
in the zipper business
around the world.
And they weren't just
state of the art.
They were creative.
And now, I prodded some
of my young colleagues
to do some statistical
work with me.
And this work is still ongoing.
It's bedeviled by complications.
But my tentative guess,
from this research so far,
is that the rate of growth
of what economists call
total factor productivity, that
part of the growth of output
per man-hour not explained
by the growth of capital
per man-hour, that total factor
productivity growth in China
is about 2%.
The thing is, it's being-- we
are being distracted from that
by the continuing
growth that comes
from other sources in China
that accounts for something
like a 7% growth rate,
or maybe a 6% or 5%
growth rate of
productivity per hour,
and even more a few years ago.
And what's this other
growth coming from?
Well, after
technological transfers
have led to the introduction
of up to date technologies
in the sophisticated companies
along the coast of China,
there's still the process of
what Dick Nelson and I call
diffusion of technologies
across the rest of the economy.
And what's going on in
China now is two things.
First of all, they're
continuing as best they can
with new technological
transfers,
although America's making that
harder and harder for them.
But at the same time,
you're getting also, so
to speak, technological
transfers from the west coast
of China to the
interior of China,
so that you're getting
strong productivity
growth through that
diffusion of the cutting edge
technologies that had
made their way to the more
pioneering companies.
What's the number for
the United States?
I said that total
factor productivity
growth had fallen in a half.
Almost like from day to
night around 1972, 1973.
What are the numbers?
Remarkably, the rate of growth
of total factor productivity
in the United States
from 1922 to 1972
was very stable--
with fluctuations,
but I mean it was not
trending anywhere,
stable around 2% per annum.
But then since 1972, it's been
stable at around 1% per annum.
So actually, China
looks like its rate
of indigenous
innovation actually
exceeds that of
the United States.
It's just being overshadowed in
China by all the productivity
gains coming from diffusion
plus any remaining
technological transfers.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: People
who are thinking
innovatively about,
what is a city?
What is-- [INAUDIBLE]?
EDMUND PHELPS: I won't
attempt to take that very far.
But I do dwell for a
page or so on cities
in the chapter of my book on the
rise of economies of dynamism.
What was going on there?
And I make the point that one
of the things going on there
was that cities were growing up.
A surprisingly large number
of cities were growing up.
In England, for
example, London was,
on some measures,
the only city around.
And then after things got
going in 1815 in Britain,
pretty soon, there
were five cities
on the same measure,
five cities in Britain.
So you had all this
interactivity going on,
with people talking to
one another, companies
exchanging views,
ideas, information.
I think that was very
integral to the explosion,
from an historical
perspective, integral
to the explosion of
productivity in Britain
that began around 1815,
almost like a shot.
And now whether you can
kind of artificially
create that by saying, hey,
let's build a city here,
and they will come, I'm
not sure they will come.
I think that would
be the big question.
Will they come?
What exactly is necessary
for them to come?
I would hate to see the federal
government launch a program
to create cities in
the United States
according to some academic
formula, most likely
by people who know not
very much about it.
On the other hand, if some
region of the country thinks
it can survive by creating a new
city, well, more power to it.
Maybe it'll work.
AUDIENCE: Do you see the
diffusion or the technology
[INAUDIBLE] transfer to
Vietnam also happening
at a similar rate to
China, or is [INAUDIBLE]?
EDMUND PHELPS: I don't know the
productivity growth numbers,
but I don't have to know the
numbers to make the educated
guess that productivity growth
has taken off in Vietnam.
And they have opportunities
for technological transfer,
not only from the
United States, but also
from other Asian countries,
such as South Korea and
such as China.
So even without having
looked at the numbers,
there's no doubt in
my mind that they've
enjoyed a very rapid
growth of productivity
in the past 10 or 15 years.
I was conscious when I was
there quite a few years ago
that there is quite a heritage
of top-down government,
a lot of government
control, and probably
a lot of social protection--
a lot of corporatism.
And so I don't
know to what extent
they've graduated out of that.
[APPLAUSE]
EDMUND PHELPS:
Thank you very much.